رونالدو بنزيما ونيمار بالزي الوطني
السعودي والاحتفالات تعم المملكه باليوم
الوطني الثالث والتسعين انطلاقه جديده
لامال ماهر اصاله تفاجئ متابعيها وحلت ترك
نجمه سكر اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
قلنا هي
تصدر وسم اليوم الوطني السعودي الثالث
والتسعين منصات التواصل في المملكه وسط
تفاعل واسع احتفالا بهذه المناسبه التي
شهدت اقامه العديد من الفعاليات والعروض
الغنائيه عمت ارجاء السعوديه وكان النصيب
الاوفر من التفاعل مع صور نجوم الدوري
السعودي وهم يرتدون الزي الوطني للمملكه
ويؤدون رقصه العرض الشهيره وتداول الرواد
منصات التواصل في السعوديه والعالم العربي
صور رونالدو وبنزيما ونيمار الذين كانوا
من ابرز النجوم الاحتفال باليوم الوطني
السعودي هذا العام
الله الله الله الله الله الله الله الله
الله ومن الفعاليات المميزه التي شهدتها
السعوديه الاسبوع الماضي بمناسبه اليوم
الوطني السعودي الثالث والتسعين ليله
اغاني المسلسلات التي ادتها اصوات سعوديه
على مسرح ابو بكر سالم في الرياض احتفالا
بذكريات الجميله للجمهور مع مسلسلات
خليجيه عربيه وتركيه اصبحت ايقونيه
ونبقى في اجواء الغناء والالبوم المصغره
الجديد الذي اطلقته المطربه المصريه امال
ماهر بعد طول غياب عبر قناهها الرسميه
الجديده على يوتيوب بعد اغلاق قناتها
الاولى التي كانت تضم كل ارشيفها الغنائي
الالبوم المصغر الجديد امال ماهر يضم خمسه
اغنيات وتجاوز عدد مشاهدات كليب اغنيه انا
كويسه من كلمات احمد المالكي والحام بلال
سرور المليون مشاهده خلال ثلاثه ايام ووجد
فيها متابعون رساله لجمهورها
[موسيقى]
وكان اخر حفل احيته امال ماهر في مدينه
العلمين الجديده في 2022 بعد جدل كبير في
منصات التواصل وقتها حول اسباب غيابها
وانقطاعها عن الغناء والظروف والضغوط التي
قيل انها تتعرض لها
وعلى سيره الاصدارات الموسيقيه الجديده
اقلقت اصاله متابعيها بحذف كافه منشوراتها
السابقه من حسابها الرسمي على انستجرام
قبل ان تفاجئهم بان سبب الحذف والترويج
لالوانها الجديد لحياتي نفسي والذي ستصدره
على جزئين بدءا من مطلع اكتوبر المقبل
واخيرا تفاعل الرواد منصات التواصل في
العالم العربي مع الاعلان الترويجي لفيلم
ثنائيا عائلي من سلسله افلام سكر وصف
بالاضخم في الشرق الاوسط الفيلم مستوحى من
روايه الكاتب الامريكي
صاحب الظل الطويل الرؤيه وكلمات النص
الغنائي لهبه مشاري حماده ومن اخراج تامر
مهدي وبطوله الفنانين المصريين ماجده زكي
ومحمد ثروت وتؤدي حلا الترك الدور الرئيسي
في الفيلم الذي سيعرض في صلاه السينما
خلال اكتوبر المقبل
عدو من واحد للعشره واحد ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
سته سبعه تمانيه عشره